2020, mình mult hảo Sun clinicians đã nhhe?
Điều trị sản rất là mė place,
nhưng rất là nhiều thứ nhất là hắn nlah cả Cambridge toànen sáng.
Дerh, được tốt vais không đánh quan.
Bận mực m– với семьöstures này pirates.
Chúng judgment sẽ cứ like to eat this food before we take your food.
Nhưng có tin trên And worst Rare ofinski force,
bà sẽiza điều về phương,
tất cả điều thiệt mạ.
Kính hàng gió ABC News đang tải cho thấy
lửa lớn mục lên tại cân cứ
càng của khỏi khổ lộ bỗng khảo.
Lực lượng hình cấp được điều động tới hiện trường để giập lửa và tìm kếm đạn nhân.
Theo Đại Tà Hâys, quá trình điều tra huy nhiên vụ việc có thể kéo dài tới sâu tháng.
Hoang tà cơ bay năm 2 được Mỹ phát triển từ những năm獄 càn chỉ chăm bún mười
và vận hành từ năm獄 càn chỉ chăm năm bi làm.
Không quân Mỹ hiện nay, suy chỉ vì đổi 122 đến 176 bê năm 2 hết
trong bê chế, sự dụng trong chiến đấu,
cũng nhiều nhiều dự án phát triển từ khi.
Chức đó, hành ngày một tiêm kích F-R người tảng của thuy quân lục triển Mỹ,
cũng gặp nạn trong lúc của lửa tại bán Washington,
sau khi công đã tốt hiệm an toàn.